So, how are we going to do the direction
prediction? We are going to have a table that
we will call, a Branch History Table, or BHT.
We will take the PC of the instruction, grab
the least significant bits, and that's what we index
into this table with. So, it's the same, as
when indexing into the BTB. But the entry here
is much smaller. The simplest predictor will simply have
a 1-bit here, that tells us if this is
a not a taken branch, meaning it's a non-branch
or a not taken branch or when it's one,
it says that this is a taken branch. If we
get a zero from here, we just increment the PC. If we get a one, we use the
BTB to tell us where to go. Just like
we were updating the BTB, we can update this once
we resolve the branch. If we resolve to a
taken branch then we put a one here and we
write the destination address into the BTB. If we
get a zero, if we, decide that the branch is
not taken or that the instruction is not a
branch. Then we put a zero here and we don't
update the BTB so that we can use the BTB
only for target addresses that we really, really need the
BTB for. Because an entry here can be only a single bit.
This table can be quite large, so we can have lots of instructions. Have
entries here, avoiding conflicts between instructions
that commonly execute, while still reserving the
small BTB, which had much fewer entries only for branches in that code.